Wins and losses
—they say that’s the measure of an athlete.
[Announcer] First championship in franchise history.
But we can’t separate the athlete from the human.
[Announcer] He’s receiving heavy boos here.
We never could.
[Mahmoud Abdul-Rauf] ...I look at the African American being oppressed in this country...
...and I don’t stand for that.
[Offscreen] The most important factor is respect, period.
Black athletes are celebrated on the court but feared off of it.
[Journalist] An NBA player tased by police.
Their talent is worth millions, but their voices deemed worthless.
But athletes have always and will always fight for victory.
[LeBron James] We will definitely not “shut up and dribble.”
Not just in basketball…
[Layshia Clarendon] We will be a voice for the voiceless.
...but for the culture.
[Journalist] Maya Moore, stepping away from basketball to fight for justice.
So we owe it to the game and to the people to share the whole story,
from court to concrete.
[Jaylen Brown] Being an NBA player don’t exclude me from no conversation.
[Protesters] What do we want?
Justice.
Because this is bigger than basketball.
[Protesters] Black lives matter!
[Dwyane Wade, at 2016 ESPYs:] It has to stop.
[Natasha Cloud] I want real change in America.
[Paul George] Breonna Taylor, rest in peace.
[Shaquille O'Neal] Can’t separate peace from freedom.
[Offscreen] Freedom and justice for all.
[Rev. Jesse Jackson in 1963:] I am
[Crowd, in response] I am
[Jackson] Somebody.
[Crowd] Somebody.
[Jackson] I am
[Crowd] I am
[Jackson] Somebody.
[Crowd] Somebody.
[Jackson] I am
[Crowd] I am
[Jackson] Somebody.
[Crowd] Somebody.
[Jackson] I am
[Crowd] I am
[Jackson] Somebody.
[Crowd] Somebody.